هذا هو يعقد مجلس هو السلم والامنه
التابعه للاتحاد الافريقي اجتماعي لاول
مره على مستوى رؤساء الدول والحكومات لبحث
الازمه السودانيه وقال مراسلنا ان رئيس
المفوضيه الافريقيه موسى فكي سيقدم خلال
هذا الاجتماع تقريرا للمجلس يتضمن رؤيه
الاتحاد الافريقي لحل الازمه السودانيه
ولن يشارك السودان في الاجتماع عملا
بميثاق مجلس السلم والامن الافريقيه الذي
يقضي بعدم السماح لاي دوله معنيه بالنزاع
بحضور جلساته
معنا مدير مكتب الجزيره محمد طه توكل محمد
ارحب بك المزيد ربما بحول ما سيتم عرضه
ايضا خلال هذا الاجتماع اليوم في هذه
الربابه والذي يتضمن رؤيه اذا الاتحاد
الافريقي بشان هذه الازمه في السودان
نعم سفيان بعد ساعتين من الان
حتنطلق الجلسه جلسه مجلس الامن وسلم
الافريقي وحسب
المصادر التي تحدثنا معها
ستكون اولا كلمه لرئيسه الدوله الحاليه
لمجلس الامن والسلم الافريقي الرئيسه
اللوغاندي يوري السفينه ثم تليها كلمه او
ملاحظات من رئيس الدوله الحاليه للاتحاد
الافريقي وثم سكرتير منظمه الليغات وثم
الامينه العام للامم المتحده ويليه طبعا
كلمه الامين العام لجامعه الدول العربيه
وتقتتم بكلمه
مفوض الاتحاد
الاوروبي ممثل الاتحاد الاوروبي ولكن هناك
الدوله الوحيده التي ستتحدث في الجلسه
المفتوحه هي وفد كلمه
ممثل جمهوريه مصر العربيه وثم هناك سبعه
دول مجاوره للسودان